hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today i'm going to give you a
tutorial on how to use a really
incredible tool called google scholar
this is not the same thing as google
again it's google scholar
and so
i am going to show you how to use it
first of all what is google scholar
google scholar
is a database for scientific research
articles basically for scholarly
literature so when you search google
scholar i'm going to click right here
you see you can get to it
at
scholar.google.com or just by googling
google scholar so when you go to google
scholar
you know it looks like this
and this is how you can make sure that
you are finding peer-reviewed scientific
literature
that will stand up to scrutiny basically
so you're not going to be getting
results you know search results that
have to do with
you know um you know blog articles or or
sort of popular press or people's
opinions this is for scientific
literature
and so i am going to start
by looking at ketrideomycosis
secretoriomycosis
is a fungal disease
that is infecting numerous amphibian
species and causing a lot of population
declines among the amphibians and even
causing some extinctions
and so that's what it is you see we've
got 7 300 results
um certainly i can
uh you know make it more specific if i
want to timporan this is a type of
antimicrobial peptide
that protects some amphibians from this
disease so you see i've limited it now
to 151 results so you can use google
scholar just like a normal search engine
except the results are scientific
articles
let me show you a few other things that
you can do with google scholar
you can look for
publications since a certain year or
even put in a custom time rate time
range let's say that i'm interested in
anything since 2015
i can limit it even farther in that way
maybe i want to go even further back and
do 2010 i get a few more hits that way
you can also sort it by date over
relevance usually i stick with relevance
and just do a a custom range for
whatever time period i'm looking for
if you're looking for patents you can
find them too in this case i'm not
looking for patents
what i also think is interesting
and useful is that you can
limit your search to review articles now
what are review articles review articles
are where the authors have taken all of
the available knowledge
from many different scientific articles
and sort of distilled it down and
summarized it into one
review
so this is sometimes called a literature
review
and so a lot of these right here may be
review articles or and you can see
there's many pages of hits here
or they might be
scientific articles where there was an
actual experiment right so an experiment
was conducted and the results of that
single experiment are being uh reported
but if you just want the review articles
basically the summaries then you can
then you can hit that review articles
and this is a great way to learn about a
topic that you don't know much about and
then you can go back to any type if you
are looking for more about
specific experiments that have been
published on
you can also create an alert so to
create an alert all you do is click here
and any time a new
anytime a new article is published and
is added to the google scholar database
then uh
if if it would show up in this in this
inquiry in this uh type of search term
then you can have it emailed to yourself
so you just hit create alert it's got
your email address right there
and you hit create alert and then you
can get email alerts whenever
new
articles about catridiomycosis and
temporanes come out for example
a few other things i want to point out
here
so we've got the title and of course you
can click on this i'm going to right
click and open in a new tab just to show
you what that looks like so i can go to
the basically the publisher's website
in this case it says purchase pdf
or i can access it through my
institution so you know not all of these
will be free
if you need something and you don't want
to pay for it sometimes you can email
the author get the email address right
here
and ask them to share the pdf with you
or you can go through an interlibrary
loan process
now if i go back to here you can see
you've also got the first few authors um
the date that's the the first few words
of the journal
and then a few things down here so
what's this star this star is to save
something so if i save it you can see it
says save to your library now i can come
over here and click on my library and
see all of the articles that i have
starred from various searches that's
just a way to save articles in one place
that are of interest to you
you can also click on this quotation
mark and this is going to give you
different types of citations so you can
just click usually i use apa i can click
on that i can do you know ctrl c to copy
it
or right click to copy if you don't want
to use the keyboard shortcuts and then i
can paste that into whatever document
i'm working on into my references or
works cited section if you use various
uh you know reference citation programs
you can get
links to those down here and then import
the citation into your program that you
use you can also see this is cited by 34
this means 34 other
scientific
papers
have cited this one
so you can kind of see like this one
cited by a hundred and fifty three this
is probably an important article in this
field
this one um doesn't seem to have been
cited by anyone yet of course it is just
a recent publication so maybe that's why
this one is a little bit older i'm only
cited by one so it might be a little bit
more niche or a little bit
you know a little bit more specific or
or less important to the field
so you can use that as kind of a measure
to find
the most cited papers in a field also if
you know you're interested in this paper
you can click on cited by 34
and these are all of the other papers
that have cited that one and so if that
first one was of interest to you some of
these might also be interesting to you
so that's another way to find papers
that are on a topic of interest you can
also click related articles which again
is going to bring up scientific
peer-reviewed articles
that
are
related to these same topics
now you'll also notice over here
sometimes there's a pdf or an html link
this is just to allow you to immediately
uh bring up that pdf providing that it's
available
and here we see that
uh that this one is so
um we can get it
and read the pdf
in this way
so let me now go back
okay and i think the only other thing i
want to point out is that you can click
right up here
and there's a few different things here
you can check on your alert you can
check on your library
you can
alter your profile google scholar is
free free free free but if you are
logging in with a google account then
you can have a profile you can also look
at there's a few other things metrics
and settings we won't talk about today
but advanced search advanced search is
where
you can look for an exact phrase
or you know i can uh remove
certain words that i might not be
interested in i can
limit
my search
to
just the title of the article i can also
search for
you know a specific author
or for a specific journal for example
and
do
do those more
remove all in title there we'll get a
few more
and get a few more results that way
if you're interested in learning about
some other
databases there is another database
called pubmed
um pubmed is very specific to medical
research whereas google scholar is much
more broad
sort of all scientific research so you
know your physics and your chemistry and
your earth science and your mathematics
along with biology and medicine if
you're interested in learning more about
pubmed for medical research i do have
another video on how to use pubmed so
please check that out
and that is going to be
it
for today from biology professor so
thank you guys very much for tuning in
let me know if you're using google
scholar let me know if it's helpful and
if you have any questions
put that in the comment box and don't
forget to subscribe
so you can
learn about more cool topics thanks for
watching bye